If we were a serious society,
we would have far harsher punishments for people who hurt children.
Like, I'm reading all these details of the Ruby Frankie case,
and I want to scream,
this woman abused her own children.
Just, like,
literal torture.
And she pleaded guilty.
Like, she's guilty.
Not like we're questioning, like,
what, did she do it or not?
You know, we don't know.
We need to, like,
go easy on her.
No, like, she's.
She's guilty.
And in the state of Utah,
the maximum
amount of prison time she can possibly do for horrific child abuse
is 30 years.
And rarely do these types of people get the maximum sentences. Right?
So she'll probably walk away in a few years.
Absolutely destroyed the lives of children,
and we literally give her a slap on the wrist, and it's like,
try harder next time.
We'll give you another chance.
Why. Why do we do this?
You hear about this all the time in every single state,
people who do horrific things to children,
and they get, like,
30 years, maximum,
10 years a year.
What are we doing?
If you are someone who hurts a child,
you should not see daylight again.
You should be put in jail.
End of story, end of conversation.
Like, our society has too many problems.
We don't need to deal with you, too.
So if you prove that you're that kind of person,
it should be goodbye.
Like, you're.
You're done. You don't get another chance.
You don't get another opportunity to do something like that again.
You're done. And this should just be an easy one for politicians,
right? Because we all seem to agree on this.
Like, it doesn't matter if you're conservative,
if you're a Liberal,
it doesn't matter how old you are.
We all seem to agree that we all hate child abusers.
This is one thing that we actually all seem to agree on.
So if you're a politician,
like, why isn't this your main focus?
Like, first of all,
because I know politicians want votes and want money and stuff.
This seems like a popular take.
Like, it seems popular to punish child abusers more severely
and to create laws that allow for more than 30 years.
So not only is it popular,
but it should also be the most important thing to you.
I can't think of any other political issue
that is more important than protecting children.